Vladimir Putin pensó que sería
cosa de unas pocas horas. Que
en apenas unos pocos días Ucrania
estaría totalmente bajo su control.
Según sus planes el ejército ruso
avanzaría a toda velocidad y ocuparía
Kyiv en apenas unos pocos días. Zelensky
y su gobierno abandonarían la capital,
el ejército ucraniano se rendiría y todo
estaría listo para el desfile de la victoria.
Putin tendría su gran gesta y Ucrania volvería a
estar bajo el control de la Madre Patria de Rusia.
C1("También encontramos algunos uniformes de
desfile, por lo que esperaban llegar a Kyiv en dos
días y luego hacer un desfile aquí. Así que ahora
podemos decir que hemos destruido completamente
sus planes".Oleksandr Hruzevych, Jefe adjunto del
Estado Mayor de las Fuerzas Terrestres de Ucrania)
Sin embargo, el curso de los acontecimientos
no pudo ser más diferente: Los ucranianos
resistieron contra viento y marea, la
ayuda internacional llegó a una escala
impensable y el ejército ruso tenía
más agujeros que un queso gruyer.
¿El resultado? No solo no hubo desfile de
la victoria. sino que un año después la
guerra continúa y Rusia ha sufrido
una cantidad gigantesca de bajas,
tanto de equipos... Como de hombres.
Según las estimaciones existentes,
más de 180 mil soldados rusos habrían muerto
o resultado heridos tan sólo durante el primer
año de la invasión. Hablamos de un
promedio de casi 500 bajas cada día.
Además, en tan solo 12 meses de guerra,
el ejército ruso ha perdido más generales
y oficiales de alto rango que en siete años en
Siria o los soviéticos durante sus 10 años de
guerra en Afganistán. Y para colmo las bajas se
han cebado sobre todo con muchas de las unidades
mejor entrenadas de Rusia como por ejemplo las
tropas aerotransportadas o la infantería naval.
Pero eso ni siquiera es todo.
Fijaos en noticias como esta:
(Según las estimaciones, Rusia
podría haber perdido más de la
mitad de sus carros de combate en Ucrania. WSJ)
Hablamos de más de 2.300 tanques. Y en
total, según el recuento llevado a cabo
por la inteligencia británica, Rusia también
habría perdido más de 4.500 vehículos blindados
de todo tipo, 63 aviones, 70 helicópteros,
12 buques navales y cientos de sistemas de
artillería. Y hablamos solo de las pérdidas
que están relativamente bien acreditadas.
Es decir, un auténtico desastre.
Para que os hagáis una idea, pese a
todos sus intentos y para asombro de
todos los ejércitos de la OTAN, Rusia no fue
siquiera capaz de tomar Kharkiv, una ciudad
situada a tan solo 50km de su frontera y uno de
sus principales objetivos durante la invasión.
Sí, a ver, no nos equivoquemos. Es cierto,
con sus misiles y su artillería, Putin está
destrozando Ucrania, ciudades como Mariupol,
Severodonetsk, Irpin, Popasna o Bahkmut así lo
atestiguan. Pero, ¿sabéis qué? Pese a todas
las pérdidas sufridas por el ejército ruso,
Putin no ha logrado ni uno solo
de sus principales objetivos:
El gobierno de Zelensky parece más fuerte que
nunca, la supuesta unificación de la nación
eslava ha sido un fracaso, Ucrania
no ha caído y para colmo sus lazos
con occidente son mucho más fuertes y
su ejército está mucho mejor armado.
Ahora bien, ¿quiere decir todo esto que
el dictador ruso Vladimir Putin podría
estar dispuesto a torcer su brazo?
Pues… Lo cierto es que no lo parece.
Cumplido un año de la invasión, según el
secretario de Defensa británico Ben Wallace,
Rusia tiene actualmente al 97% de sus fuerzas
de combate desplegadas en la guerra de Ucrania.
Y lo que es peor, ningún bando parece
tener la victoria al alcance de la mano.
Entonces la pregunta es, ¿Cómo demonios
va a terminar este infierno? ¿De qué
forma se puede poner fin a la guerra de
Ucrania?¿Qué escenarios están sobre la
mesa de las grandes cancillerías internacionales?
Pues…bien, veámoslo.
[Pero antes dadme solo un segundo porque
me gustaría contaros algo: la familia
VisualPolitik vuelve a crecer. Si el año pasado
nació VisualEconomik, ahora lo hace Not News,
un nuevo espacio 100% gratuito que nace
como una newsletter y pronto como una web
y más. Las noticias se suceden cada minuto, sin
embargo nuestra vida no cambia ni mucho menos tan
rápido. Por eso nuestra intención con Not News es
centrarnos en el contexto que explica las propias
noticias. El complemento perfecto a VisualPolitik.
Os podéis registrar gratuitamente en Notnews.com
Y si queréis más siempre podréis sumaros a la
comunidad de Patreon. Gracias a todos los que
nos apoyais podemos seguir mejorando y creando
proyectos como este. Mil gracias desde aquí.
Pero ahora sí, continuemos.]
T1(EN BUSCA DE LA PUERTA DE SALIDA)
A comienzos del mes de octubre del
2021, se celebró una importantísima
reunión en el despacho más importante
del mundo: el Despacho Oval. Entre otros,
estuvieron presentes en la reunión el Presidente
de Estados Unidos, Joe Biden, el Director de la
CIA, William Burns, el Asesor de Seguridad
Nacional de la Casa Blanca, Jake Sullivan y
el Jefe del Estado Mayor Conjunto de las
Fuerzas Armadas, el General Mark Milley.
¿Cuál fue el motivo de la reunión?
Pues… Ni más ni menos que Analizar
las últimas informaciones de inteligencia
que señalaban que Vladimir Putin podría
estar a punto de invadir Ucrania. No hablamos
de conjeturas sino de informaciones. El riesgo
era completamente real. Hablamos
de comienzos de octubre del 2021,
casi 5 meses antes de que finalmente las
huestes del Kremlin se lanzaran sobre Ucrania.
En aquella reunión, tal y como ha confirmado el
propio Milley, se acordaron 4 líneas de actuación:
(Primero, había que evitar a toda costa
un conflicto armado entre Rusia y la OTAN.
Segundo, de producirse la guerra habría que hacer
todo lo posible para contenerla dentro
de los límites geográficos de Ucrania.
Tercero, resultaba clave fortalecer y cohesionar
la OTAN. Había que coger el
teléfono lo antes posible.
Y cuarto, y el punto posiblemente clave,
no solo de la reunión, sino de todo lo que
hemos vivido después: Había que empoderar
a Ucrania y darles los medios para luchar.)
Sí, queridos amigos de VisualPolitik,
esa fue ni más ni menos la reunión en
la que Estados Unidos decidió que
esta vez no miraría de perfil.
Si Rusia quebrantaba la soberanía
y la libertad de Ucrania,
los ucranianos no serían abandonados a su suerte.
Esa fue la reunión en la que se fijó
la estrategía que luego poco a poco
se ha ido desarrollando y que junto a la
solidaridad de muchos aliados europeos,
y sobre todo, la tenacidad, el
resistencia y la valentía de los
Ucranianos han permitido que Vladimir Putin
se haya estrellado contra un enorme muro.
Kyiv continúa siendo libre, los aliados
internacionales han apoyado a Ucrania,
en total han comprometido más de 160.000
millones de dólares en ayuda militar,
humanitaria y financiera. Una enorme
cantidad de recursos que tiene que
ser capaz de cubrir las necesidades
de Ucrania hasta finales del 2023.
C2("Nadie pensó que los rusos comenzarían una
guerra medieval en el siglo XXI. Este conflicto
va a cambiar la cara de Europa tanto como lo
hizo la Segunda Guerra Mundial". James Risch,
Senador republicano por Idaho y miembro del
Comité de Relaciones Exteriores del Senado.)
Pero evidentemente aunque el hecho de
que Kyiv siga libre es una gran noticia,
la guerra, la destrucción y la aniquilación
de vidas sigue siendo un escenario terrible.
Así que la pregunta es, ¿qué salidas puede
tener la guerra? Pues bien, aquí os dejamos
4 caminos para que la guerra llegue a su fin.
Por supuesto, no todos son igual de deseables.
Alguno de ellos, empezando por el primero
sería terrible para todos. Atentos.
T2(1. DEJAR CAER A UCRANIA)
Putin contaba con que el resto del mundo no
hiciera nada. Que el resto de países se quedarán
de brazos cruzados viendo como impone su voluntad
en un país que él mismo no considera como tal.
¿Y sabéis qué? Eso en cierto modo todavía
podría ocurrir. Ahí tenemos por ejemplo los
casos de Trump y su entorno en Estados Unidos,
de Podemos en España o de Le Pen en Francia.
Y, claro, no nos engañemos, si se
cortará el suministro de Ucrania,
tarde o temprano lo más probable es que este país
terminara cayendo. O en el mejor de los casos
negociando un alto el fuego que sería toda una
victoria para Putin y un desastre para Ucrania.
De hecho, el cansancio de occidente sigue siendo
una de las grandes bazas de Vladimir Putin y lo
que en buena parte explica por qué demonios sigue
erre que erre con su plan. Y precisamente por eso
el viaje de Biden a Kyiv fue tan importante
como una clara manifestación de compromiso.
Amigos, abandonar a Ucrania supondría
dejar a los ucranianos bajo el yugo de
Moscú. O en otras palabras, frente a un montón
de represión y purgas de todo tipo. Los cientos
de cuerpos en muchos casos torturados
de Bucha e Izyum son un buen ejemplo.
Pero no solo eso. También sería algo
catastrófico para el resto del mundo.
Pensadlo bien, le estaríamos diciendo
a todos los tiranos del planeta que no
solo tienen barra libre para hacer lo que
les plazca cuando les plazca, sino que,
además, los hechos consumados y la política
de la fuerza son la mejor garantía de éxito….
Poned ahora esa reflexión en lugares como Taiwán,
Corea o Moldavia y tendréis la mejor
receta para el peor de los mundos.
Precisamente por eso esta opción
está completamente descartada.
Lo que nos lleva directamente
a la segunda salida. Atentos
T3(2. CONGELAR LA GUERRA)
Primero la ofensiva rusa y luego
las contraofensivas ucranianas,
en el primer aniversario de la invasión,
la guerra se encontraba ya en una especie
de letargo… Al menos desde el punto de
vista territorial. Los grandes choques se han
limitado a puntos muy concretos como Bahkmut.
Los rusos han enviado muchos miles de hombres para
reforzar sus defensas y atrincherarse y así
intentar defender el territorio conquistado.
Es evidentemente que las bajas que
ha sufrido Rusia han sido enormes.
Pero Ucrania también ha sufrido
una gigantesca cantidad de bajas,
tanto militares como civiles, y
aunque ha recibido mucho material
militar todavía no parece suficiente
como para ganar claramente la guerra.
Si los aliados mantienen su apoyo pero reducen
las entregas el conflicto podría alargarse durante
años y llegar a congelarse. Además, el propio
paso del tiempo podría favorecer esta salida…
El agotamiento, el cansancio, la pérdida de
atención social y mediática o el miedo a otra
crisis energética podrían hacer que muchos
países terminaran buscando una salida cómoda,
esto es intentar congelar el conflicto y
en cierta forma recobrar la normalidad.
Incluso si Rusia termina lanzando una ofensiva,
logrando nuevos territorios y luego
pidiera alcanzar un acuerdo de paz
es posible que muchos países presionen
a Kyiv para que esto se lleve a cabo.
Y, ¿sabéis qué? La propia Ucrania podría no
tener más remedio que aceptar la presencia
Rusia en su territorio y una sensación
de miedo y frustración permanente.
C3 ("Seguimos repitiendo que Rusia no
debe ganar, pero ¿qué significa eso? Si
la guerra continúa el tiempo suficiente con
esta intensidad, las pérdidas de Ucrania se
volverán insoportables". Un alto cargo francés
en declaraciones al Wall Street Journal)
Por supuesto, además, esto supondría mucho
más dolor durante mucho más tiempo para
los ucranianos, y desde luego, no está
claro el futuro que tendría este país.
¿Realmente se podría reconstruir
Ucrania y atraer a los capitales
extranjeros y las empresas si
el país técnicamente continúa
en guerra, tiene parte de su territorio
invadido y la amenaza rusia continúa?
Y, claro, no podemos pasar por alto
que la economía ucraniana está hecha
trizas y que sus infraestructuras están
muy dañadas. Es decir, que eso podría
suponer una condena a medio plazo. La
incapacidad de que el país sea viable.
Además, ¿No podría Rusia volver a
retomar su ofensiva dentro de unos
pocos años cuándo Ucrania esté más
debilitada y ellos hayan conseguido
restablecer parte de su fuerza militar,
aunque sea a base de entrenar reclutas?
En cualquier caso sería en cierto modo una
victoria para Rusia. Una victoria menos clara,
pero en última instancia una victoria. Se habrían
anexionado buena parte de Ucrania y al final la
comunidad internacional no hubiera hecho mucho
más allá del efecto gaseosa para evitarlo.
C4 ( "Pekín está observando de cerca,
para ver el precio que Rusia paga,
o la recompensa que recibe, por su
agresión. Lo que está sucediendo en
Europa hoy puede suceder en Asia mañana". Jens
Stoltenberg, Secretario General de la OTAN)
Y, ojo, porque de no incrementar el suministro
de armas a Ucrania este escenario es bastante
probable… Y quizás la mej or salida para
Rusia y tal vez también para el propio Putin.
Por eso algunos aliados, como Alemania o Francia,
dos países que no estan particularmente cómodos
con la guerra - que cada uno piense en
los motivos - se han convencido de otra
alternativa, la tercera posibilidad
para poder poner fin a los combates.
T4(3. PENSANDO EN 2024)
En 2024 hay elecciones en Rusia… Y por
eso Putin y su entorno podrían ser los
mayores interesados en alcanzar una salida al
conflicto antes de esa fecha. No sea que un
revés militar y económico ponga en tela de juicio
su continuidad al frente del Kremlin. Es decir,
si la guerra no ha terminado… Muchos
círculos rusos podrían presionar para
quitarse de enmedio a un presidente
fracasado para colocar a un nuevo líder
al frente… Aprovechando lo que técnicamente
sería el fin del mandato del presidente ruso.
Pues bien, para evitar ese escenario
Putin podría estar dispuesto a negociar
y hacer concesiones. Eso al menos
es lo que parecen pensar tanto el
presidente de Francia, Emmanuel Macron
como el Canciller alemán, Olaf Scholz.
Eso sí para que todo esto fuera
posible Ucrania tiene que estar
en disposición de hacer daño a
Rusia… Lo que exige la entrega
rápida de muchas más armas. ¿Leopards,
tanques? Pues por ahí van los tiros.
C5 (“Lo que necesitamos ahora es que
Ucrania lance una ofensiva militar
que haga retroceder el frente ruso
para abrir el camino para un retorno
a las negociaciones" Emmanuel
Macron, Presidente de Francia)
Y quizás ni siquiera haría falta esperar a 2024.
(Una ofensiva ucraniana en el sureste
capaz de alcanzar el Mar de Azov,
recuperar todo el área de Zaporizhia y poner
a Crimea a tiro de la artillería, podría ser
suficiente para forzar una negociación. Esto es
lo que se conoce como la teoría del Big Bang.)
Ahora bien, de llegar a una salida
negociada… ¿Nos podemos realmente
fiar de que Rusia cumpla su parte del trato?
Pues lo cierto es que la historia nos dice que No.
Ucrania, de hecho, es un buen ejemplo. No
olvidéis que la propia Rusia garantizar en
el Memorándum de Budapest la seguridad y la
soberanía completa de Ucrania - incluyendo
Crimea - a cambio de que este país
le entregara sus armas nucleares.
Porque, amigos, amigas, al
disolverse la Unión Soviética,
Ucrania se convirtió en el tercer país
del mundo con más armas nucleares.
(Por eso, a cambio de estas posibles
negociaciones, los países occidentales
le darían a Ucrania una seguridad mucho
más tangible: el suficiente equipo militar
como para desincentivar cualquier
nueva agresión rusa en el futuro:
hablamos de blindados modernos, misiles, una
fuerza aérea y todo lo que sea necesario.
Incluso se podría plantear un acuerdo
con la OTAN. Y como estaríamos hablando
de una salida pactada, el país podría
intentar volver a ponerse en marcha.)
De esta forma Ucrania podría quedar blindada
y tener futuro a cambio de ciertas cesiones
en un acuerdo que aunque malo sería mucho
más asumible que el del escenario anterior.
Esta parece ser, al menos, la
percepción del tándem París-Berlín,
que según dicen hoy por hoy Londrés tampoco
ve del todo mal. Además Ucrania no correría
el riesgo de lo que pudiera pasar en 2025
si se produjera un cambio en la Casa Blanca.
Y, ojo, porque a día de hoy esta
puede ser, con mucha diferencia,
el final de la guerra más probable.
Claro que todavía nos queda otro posible
camino. Uno con muchos adeptos en Ucrania,
Polonia, los Países Bálticos
y, también, los Estados Unidos.
¿De qué estoy hablando?
Ahora mismo la vamos a ver.
T5(4. LA VICTORIA A CUALQUIER PRECIO)
El 2023 empezó con muy
buenas noticias para Ucrania:
Hablamos del compromiso para
entregarles decenas y decenas,
cientos de vehículos blindados entre otro mucho
equipamiento… Incluyendo tanques modernos.
Hablamos, Bradleys, Strykers, Marders,
AMX-10; Challenger II, Leopards,
Baterías Patriot, etcétera, etcétera.
Si estas entregas se mantienen y se
incrementan con el paso del tiempo el curso
de la guerra podría cambiar por completo.
Especialmente si se entregan más HIMARS,
más tanques y misiles de largo radio. Y
no digamos ya si se les proveyera
de más y mejores aviones y drones.
Inicialmente se fue muy comedido con
la entrega de armas para, por ejemplo,
no tener asumir una derrota ante Rusia si
finalmente Ucrania no aguantaba el envite.
Y tiene sentido. De otra forma
la OTAN hubiera quedado muy
tocada y el liderazgo de Estados Unidos,
terriblemente cuestionado. Las implicaciones
en el resto del mundo hubieran sido enormes.
Sin embargo ahora las cosas
son completamente distintas.
Y es que, veréis, según muchos informes
el ejército ruso podría estar exhausto y
falto de equipamiento. Lo que explicaría porque
les cuesta tanto realizar cualquier ofensiva.
Es verdad que Rusia ha enviado muchos
hombres nuevos gracias al reclutamiento,
pero también es verdad que la fuerza de combate
de estas unidades no parece particularmente alta.
Es por eso que una sucesión de fuertes
contragolpes del ejército ucraniano
podría hacer saltar por los aires las líneas
de defensa rusas. Es decir que puede existir
la oportunidad de ir a por todas, derrotar a
Rusia y obligar a su ejército a retroceder e,
incluso, abandonar Ucrania, tal vez
con la única excepción de Crimea.
De esa manera el daño para el régimen de
Putin sería potencialmente irreparable . ¿Qué
es lo que hace falta para conseguirlo? Un
apoyo militar mucho más grande y decidido.
Por supuesto, esta posibilidad por
un lado pondría de nuevo sobre la
mesa el riesgo nuclear, pero de eso ya
os hablamos en un pasado vídeo aquí en
VisualPolitik. Os contamos porque era
improbable que Moscú recurriera a esa
posibilidad. Básicamente porque no ganaría
nada. Pero por supuesto el riesgo existe.
Sobre todo, porque en segundo lugar, este
escenario pondría en jaque al líder ruso.
Evidentemente perder una guerra contra
un país mucho más pequeño y muchos menos
recursos no es plato de bueno gusto, más
aún cuando la modernización militar y el
volver a hacer de Rusia un país fuerte
fue la prioridad número 1 del régimen
de Putin durante más de dos décadas.
Además, si algo nos dice la historia,
es que un régimen tiene muy complicado
sobrevivir cuándo pierde una guerra.
Pues bien, pese a todas las bajas y todo
el dolor sufrido. Hoy por hoy esta es la
opción con más partidarios en la propia Ucrania.
Queridos amigos, amigas, estos son los
4 escenarios posibles para que veamos
terminar la guerra de Ucrania. Ya veis que
en cualquier caso las “mejores” salidas
parecen exigir que se le entregen
muchas más armas a Ucrania. Esto es
algo que casi todo el mundo parece haber
entendido. Incluso el propio Olaf Scholz.
Así que ahora el turno es para ti:
¿Qué estrategia te parece más interesante
seguir? ¿Qué harías de tener que tomar tú la
decisión? Déjanos tu respuesta en
los comentarios y abramos debate.
Y ahora si este vídeo os ha resultado interesante
no olvidéis darle a like y suscribiros
a VisualPolitik y, también, a Not News.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.